i was telling everyone about your book
the story of you
going golfing with your buddies
and you [ __ ] the front of your pants
is so wild to me because i was like when
you wrote i was like
who shits the front of their pants and
how does that happen
and you you academically went through
exactly how it happens and it's one of
the greatest stories of all time
it's like one of those sports science uh
shows where they show the physics of how
it can happen
how old were you at the time i'm way too
old like 30
32. who are the guys with you when you
[ __ ] your pants are these guys who are
titans of
the industry or uh i didn't know them
very well at all and they were like
let's play golf i was like sure i'll
join you guys
and so we're out and we're walking to
the next tee
and i've my stomach's been bothering me
for a while and suddenly i'm like you
know what i gotta
i gotta do something about this so i'm
like guys i just have to
pee really quick um i'll meet you guys
at the next tee
great cover story absolutely so i pulled
down my shorts
but i haven't gotten the shorts far
enough
down so that the way while i'm
while i'm squatting it hits the front of
the front of the shorts now you're
[ __ ] so
there's a deer look watching me do this
like standing there
looking me in the eyes horrified while
i'm doing this
i have to take my shorts and underwear
off so that i'm just in
golf cleats and a polo shirt
i take use my underwear to clean up
throw my underwear into the woods and
then
pull my shorts back up and think that
i'm
kind of in the clear right and then join
them at the t
like this is this has definitely been
five ten minutes which is so long
and i'm sweating i feel like i go back
and then i'm there and i look and i see
that i've
got the front i coated the front of my
pants so i just
i like was social distancing before that
way before that was a thing
walking like 20 feet away from them down
the fairway and we played another six
holes of golf
and then i was like i'm not feeling
great ran to my car ran home
burned the shorts and just tried to move
on with my life
i can tell you another quick story if
you want i went to
hawaii with uh will forte you know will
forte was on
snl so we're there we're having dinner
and i'm getting on a night flight home
i start driving from the dinner to the
airport and i'm gonna leave from there
it's only a 20 minute drive but halfway
through i'm like oh my god i really have
to go
i have to like this is bad i go into the
into the woods i have horrible diarrhea
then
obviously as you know my system use the
underwear to clean up
throw the underwear in the woods then
the next year
will forte's like we're going back to
hawaii you want to come and i was like
sure
he makes me take him to where i think
it was in the woods that i went
and the whole group like 10 people that
flew there
spend the first moments in their of
their vacation in hawaii
searching the woods and it's and after
like five or ten minutes
forte comes out with a stick holding my
underwear
my god oh my god a year later in the
hawaii in the hawaiian rain forest
holding my underwear on a stick when you
look at you you look like a guy who
would not [ __ ] his pants you know what i
mean
just stand up for a second so we can see
the front of your pants
a quick check a quick check status check
do me this favor if you do [ __ ] your
pants again even after this interview
just call us and let us know so we can
talk to you about it i think those are
great stories
i promise no one else is giving me that
invite so i promise i will